30 ist opfer verpiss dich doch
menschen nicht ein paradebeispiel dafür
wollen frauen niemals wählen dürfen
sollen durch im bestreiten
er ist doch dein trockenshampoo selten
so was erbärmliches wie dich gesehen
spring von einer brücke damit tust der
gesellschaft wenn riesen dienst ich bin
wie paralysiert dass man da gesessen und
habe das wirklich glauben können weil im
sekundentakt dass das gekommen dass wir
jedes mal wie es würde mich jemand quasi
digital zusammenschlagen
man fühlt sich wirklich wünscht sich
halt gerade wenn man eine sexualisieren
de nachricht bekommt heute praktiziert
und entmenschlicht diese nachrichten
waren in den postfächern da rein und sie
sind auch der grund warum sie sich so
fühlen
vielleicht habt ihr das auch schon mal
erlebt habt nachrichten bekommen die
euch verletzt haben die einfach als
überflüssig empfunden habt von fremden
oder von leuten die ihr kanntet ist das
tatsächlich schon mal passiert mir hat
mal jemand den ich nicht kannte ein
fremder ein foto von mir genommen und
porträtfoto dass sich irgendwo mal
hochgeladen hatte hat das auf einen
anderen körper montiert und mir dann per
nachricht geschickt ich weiß noch dass
ist jetzt zwar schon ein paar jahre her
aber ich habe mich damals total dafür
geschämt und habe ihm dann wie aus panik
ich es geblockt und gemeldet und dann
doch auch beschlossen einfach schnell
mein profil zu löschen
mittlerweile weiß ich so was muss man
nicht einfach hinnehmen und ich bin auch
nicht die einzige der so was passiert
das ist eine form von gewalt digitaler
gewalt und dagegen kann man sich wehren
und deswegen geht es in diesem video
darum die betroffene von digitaler
gewalt damit umgehen und wie man sich
dagegen wehren kann
[Musik]
charlotte weise hat bei instagram mehr
als 145.000 verloren auf ihrem profil
geht es um body positive t und einen
nachhaltigen lebensstil und dafür
bekommt sie natürlich von ihren
followern ziemlich viel gutes feedback
aber das hat es mir eben interview
erzählt bekommt sie auch ziemlich viel
hass ab in welchem depression politik
vor allem geflüchteten dinge wenn ich
dazu was ich auch mache man immer wieder
gegenwind da wie fühlt sich das an
diese nachrichten zu lesen diese
kommentare zu bekommen so wirklich ganz
persönlich bei dir nicht so tut als wäre
ich in den innenraum ganz klein in der
ecke und keiner liebt einen wenn das so
ganz viele rechte auf den kopf kommen
die mehr als einem schreiben wie ich
hoffe dass du vergewaltigt wirst von
einem geflüchteten damit du merkst dass
sie nicht mehr sind so was muss nicht
mehr schön und reist mit einer anhöhe
und da hatte ich schon teilweise 1 und
blogs die leute du stellst
kommentarfunktion aus wenn du merkst da
kommt was was tust du denn sonst
ich versuche mich zu schützen indem ich
halt so was mache mit dass ältere leute
dokumentieren können und tauschen sich
mit anderen bürgern aus natürlich auch
sehr bestärkend wir haben gerade gestern
wieder in der gruppe geschrieben was
sollen wir dagegen machen können dass
wir uns immer wieder so postings
vorbereiten wo wir alle gemeinsam
projekte umsetzen um auf die dinge
aufmerksam zu machen wie viel herz hat
online ist der begriff digitale gewalt
bezeichnet alle formen von gewalt die
mit technischen mitteln ausgeübt werden
oder in der digitalen welt stattfinden
also zum beispiel auf sozialen
plattformen
dazu gehören dix drohung und beleidigung
sexualisierte nachrichten oder
kommentare die verschickt werden
stalking oder aber das verbreiten von
geklauten bildern die dann verändert
werden und weiter veröffentlicht werden
betroffen davon sind vor allem menschen
die auch in der realen welt wenn man sie
so nennen will
auch von diskriminierung vermehrt
betroffen sind das hat mir josephine
ballon erzählt sie arbeitet bei der
beratungsstelle hate da sehen wir vor
allem
der lgbt community sehr viele fälle
wir sehen das vor allem aktivistinnen
die sich verschiedene gesellschaftliche
themen und für eine offene demokratische
gesellschaft einsetzen
häufig angewendet werden und wir sehen
auch dass auch wenn man jetzt
zahlenmäßig nicht von einer einer
minderheit sprechen kann dass es vor
allem auch viele frauen betrifft das
team von red hill iv betroffenen sich
gegen die digitale gewalt zu wehren wie
dazu später mehr
zuerst will ich einen blick auf das
ausmaß dessen werfen es gibt kaum
studien dazu was es aber gibt es eine
repräsentative umfrage des
kinderhilfswerk plan international
die haben mit jungen frauen darüber
gesprochen inwiefern sie von digitaler
gewalt betroffen sind und dass es dabei
rausgekommen
58 der befragten aus 22 ländern gaben an
schon einmal im internet belästigt
worden zu sein
in deutschland waren es sogar 70 prozent
der befragten sie erleben die digitale
gewalt auf instagram facebook youtube
snap chat tik tok oder twitter und das
hat folgen
23 prozent der betroffenen gaben an
wegen der beleidigungen herabsetzungen
und bedrohungen ein angst zu erleben die
körperlich spürbar ist
32 empfinden mentalen und emotionalen
stress da durch das erleben von hass im
netz sorgt für ein geringeres
selbstwertgefühl und weniger
selbstbewusstsein und die umfrage zeigt
auch betroffene von digitaler gewalt
ziehen sich aus sozialen medien zurück
schreiben keine post mehr oder verlassen
die plattform ganz das kann ich absolut
nachvollziehen
man will ja seine zeit nicht an einem
ort verbringen wo man sich unwohl fühlt
oder nicht sicher fühlt auch wenn es
orte sind die hier im handy online sind
und damit es gar nicht erst soweit kommt
und damit auch mehr aufmerksamkeit für
das problem digitale gewalt geschaffen
wird veröffentlichte instagram account
anti flirt lng nachrichten wie diese
hier weißt du wenn mein langes
hereinkommt wirst du verschmerzen
schreiben
wie hast du das zur sache ich bin ich
will christ duell spielen was machst
hätte ist heute zeit zu treffen und
treffen wir uns heute lust auf knutschen
heute wurzel fucking problem lust auf
knutschen hey mein alter abnimmt des
accounts sind kim chakraborty und caro
neuwirth angefangen hat es einfach weil
wir beide persönliche erfahrungen
irgendwo in dem bereich gemacht haben
dass wir halt selber viele solche
übergriffigen nachrichten bekommen haben
einerseits auf instagram social media
andererseits auf dating plattformen und
deshalb irgendwie gekannt haben von
unseren freundinnen die ganzen
geschichten und gefühlt ich kenne keine
meiner freundinnen oder meiner
weiblichen bekannten die das nun schon
mal passiert ist und den ich schon mal
über griffige nachrichten bekommen haben
in irgendeiner weise ich glaube das
wichtigste für uns ist bewusst sein in
alle richtungen zu beschaffen
sowohl für uns natürlich als auch für
betroffene einst auch für täter innen
weil ich glaube es gibt noch nicht so
ein richtiges bewusstsein dafür was
eigentlich über griffigkeit und
grenzüberschreitung ist weil ich denke
viele menschen verbinden über
griffigkeit mit einem maskierten mann
der aus dem busch bringt aber das ist
eben nicht nur das sondern sind auch
kleine berührungen oder in unserem fall
eben nachrichten die grenze
überschreiten sind und ich glaube das
muss halt in das bewusstsein von allen
gehen da wird sich das ändern kann
funktioniert das was ihr macht was ihr
euch vorgenommen habt also wenn ihr sagt
ihr wollt aufmerksamkeit für das problem
also sofern es schaffen ihr dann powert
ja auch die in betroffenen dadurch finde
ich es halt so was von ok das wird
gesehen und ihr seid nicht allein damit
und so wehren wir uns dagegen
funktioniert das denn ich glaube die
allerwenigsten die darüber nachdenken
was sie schon der vergangenheit getan
haben schreiben uns denn wirklich weil
das ja auch eine verbindung ist einen
seite zu schreiben die sich mit sowas
beschäftigt hey ich hab so was was ihr
schon was ihr postet schon gemacht
vielleicht scheint man sich auch dafür
und wir haben ein paar wenige
nachrichten bekommen
und die hatten also den inhalt ich habe
darüber nachgedacht ich hab ja das
screenshots angeschaut und ich habe
gemerkt ich habe tatsächlich so was auch
schon gemacht und das hat mich jetzt zum
nachdenken angeregt und ich versuche so
was nicht mehr zu machen
ich habe den account angeschaut und
gemerkt dass das problem viel größer ist
als ich dachte
diese nachrichten erreichen und so
glaube ich so ein verhältnis noch öfter
sie wussten gar nicht dass es so schlimm
ist sie wussten gar nicht dass es so
häufig passiert sie wussten gar nicht
wie schlimm das ist und wie schlimm das
für die betroffenen ist wenn sie solche
nachrichten bekommen und einfach diese
aufmerksamkeit auf das thema zu lenken
ist glaube ich einfach irgendwo schon
notwendig gewesen
immerhin scheint der ein oder andere zu
verstehen dass das ungefragte zusenden
von sex angeboten oder beleidigungen im
netz nicht okay sind sowie dass sie auf
der straße auch nicht okay wäre wichtig
übrigens es geht beim veröffentlichen
dieser nachrichten kommentare und posts
nicht darum die täterin bloßzustellen
anti flirten geht es darum
aufmerksamkeit für das problem zu
schaffen
und deswegen haben caro und kim auch die
absender der post und nachrichten immer
unkenntlich gemacht was aber wenn man
online mit hass überschüttet wird und
der auch ins echte leben überschwappen
darüber habe ich mit natascha strobl
gesprochen die wienerin ist
politikwissenschaftlerin und beschäftigt
sich vor allen dingen mit rechtsextremen
bewegungen auf twitter veröffentlicht
sie dann auch ihre analysen und macht
kein hehl daraus dass sie sehr linke
politische einstellungen hat und dafür
kassiert sie ziemlich viel hass wie sie
mir im interview erzählt hat aber es
geht vom aufforderungen ich solle von
der brücke springen ich sollte mich
umbringen bis hin zu alten vater
gestorben ist das ist die kondolenzbuch
ausfindig gemacht wurde krank der sache
angeschrieben wurden
dein vater wird ausgebuddelt und dann in
einzelteilen auf einem haufen vor der
haustüre abgeladen
also gerade wenn sie so ganz ins
persönliche gehen die dinge sind es
besitzt hier trotzdem einfach daheim auf
der couch ist alleine und hat das vor
sich und das ist wie ein schlag einfach
und dabei bleibt es dann nicht sie hat
schon schützt uns erlebt die vielleicht
online gestartet haben aber deren
konsequenzen sie dann auch im echten
realen leben auf der straße zu spüren
bekommen hat
ich sehe diesen unterschied zwischen
zwischen digitale welt und wie echte
welt wisse schön heißt nicht denn ich
bin ein echter mensch und ich bekomme es
ab und ich bin ein mensch der dahinter
sitzt und das liest und die anderen
leute sind auch menschen die das
schreiben
und nur weil sie ein anderes mädchen
wählen oder weil sie sich in hemd fühlen
weil sie das über twitter schreiben sie
mir trotzdem menschen und vor allem für
das sehr schnell dazu weil man eine
person markiert zu zielscheiben
pausenlos und menschlich im internet
dann bekommt diese person ist auch
irgendwann im realen welt der und ich
habe das auch schon gehabt wie gesagt
ich bin keine naiven fluffigen rosa welt
wo ich glaube dass nichts passiert man
hat mich schon mit einem luftdruckgewehr
ins fenster geschossen ich bin schon
gekränkt worden formats ist man hat mir
schon meine presse geoutet ich kann
total verstehen dass das angst macht
denn es hat ja längst nichts mehr mit
kritik oder diskussionen zu tun die
einfach ein bisschen heftiger ablaufen
würden um sich zu wehren löschen
blockieren oder melden charlotte weise
und natascha strobl dann diese
kommentare und userinnen aber wenn es
richtig heftig wird dann gibt es auch
die möglichkeit sich juristisch gegen
diese art von digitaler gewalt zu wehren
dass postings dafür gibt es keinen
eigenen straftatbestand aber es gibt
formen von digitaler gewalt die trotzdem
angezeigt werden können
ich habe beim bka mal nachgefragt und es
sind folgende beleidigung üble nachrede
verleugnung bedrohung nötigung
volksverhetzung oder öffentliche
aufforderung zu straftaten das im
internet geschieht ist genauso strafbar
wie es zum beispiel im analogen leben
auf der straße strafbar wäre die gesetze
gelten auch im internet auch wenn sie
ihren leuten das offenbar nicht bewusst
ist es gibt zwei wege sich rechtlich
gegen digitale gewalt wie beleidigung
oder nötigungen zu wehren und zwar
einmal über das zivilrecht und der
andere weg ist über das strafrecht bei
strafrechtlichen schritten geht es darum
dass die täterin bestraft werden und bei
zivilrechtlichen maßnahmen geht es darum
dass betroffene entschädigung bekommen
und dass die täterin die kommentare zum
beispiel auch löschen müssen wichtig ist
immer dass wenn man davon betroffen ist
dass man die url des kommentars oder der
nachricht sichert und dass man einen
screenshot macht der dann auch später
vor gericht ja dem ganzen standhalten
kann sozusagen
dafür ist es wichtig dass zum beispiel
uhrzeit datum und der kontext des ganzen
auch erkennbar sind
wer bei all dem hilfe braucht er bekommt
die bei beratungsstellen wie zum
beispiel denn es ist nicht immer so
einfach das fängt schon damit an dass
man ja häufig gar nicht weiß wer die
täterin sind weil die im netz anonym
sind und es gibt auch noch andere hürden
wenn man sich dann schließt zum beispiel
alleine ohne anwalt ohne unterstützung
strafanzeige zu erstatten ist leider
dass die fälle häufig nicht sehr ernst
genommen werden das heißt es passiert
leider betroffenen heute auch immer noch
dass sie dann zur polizeidienststelle
gehen was sie leider oft müssen weil
nicht alle bundesländer onlinewache
anbieten oder wenn ich alle online warum
ist auch zum beispiel ermöglichen
dokumente hochzuladen die screenshots
zum beispiel dass sie dort auch sehr
viel ablehnung stoßen dann heißt es doch
nur im internet
warum schreiben sie denn so was
überhaupt und melden sie sich doch
einfach ab ist doch nicht so schlimm
das ist leider eine sensibilisierung von
der wir heute auch immer noch hören
würden sie denn sagen es lohnt sich dann
trotzdem
ja es lohnt sich natürlich das würde ich
auch nicht das machen was ich ja aber
was ich mache und was hält macht ist
einfach so dass wir gegen das was da
passiert uns auch wehren müssen und die
erfolgserlebnisse die es gibt
die zeigen dass ja auch sicherlich sind
nicht alle betroffenen aus sehr guten
gründen
reisen mit in die öffentlichkeit zu
gehen weil natürlich vorprogrammiert ist
dass eventuell der nächste held daumen
gleich wieder kommt oder dass ihnen da
dann auch wieder hass entgegenschlägt
ganz einfach dafür aber natürlich
ermutigt es auch andere betroffene die
die gleichen erfahrungen machen und die
vielleicht zum ersten mal sehen das ist
dass man sich überhaupt dagegen wehren
kann und dass es eben auch erfolgreich
sein kann und für die draußen denn die
erfolge erzielt haben da ist es einfach
ein sehr gutes gefühl zu wissen dass man
da jetzt mal nicht machtlos war
auch wenn es natürlich ein sehr
steiniger weg ist also nochmal
zusammengefasst digitale gewalt trifft
vor allen dingen aktivistin minderheiten
und frauen und sie kann genau so
verletzend sein wie eine echte prügelei
im analogen leben oder eine
ausgesprochene beleidigung nur weil das
ganze im internet stattfindet heißt es
nicht dass man sich nicht dagegen wehren
kann
im gegenteil es gibt beratungsstellen
die helfen einem auch dabei links zu
head & co packen wir euch mal unten in
die beschreibung wichtig ist redet mit
euren freunden oder anderen vertrauten
darüber wenn ihr euch online bedrängt
fühlt oder wenn euch post und
nachrichten verletzt niemand soll damit
alleine sein und auch wenn etwas nicht
juristisch relevant ist heißt es nicht
dass man sich nicht dagegen wehren kann
man kann aufmerksamkeit für das problem
schaffen zum beispiel sowie die mädels
von anti flirt in das tun indem sie die
post veröffentlichen weil so kann man
ins gespräch darüber und spricht darüber
wo die grenzen sind auch im internet
habt ihr auch schon digitale gewalt
erlebt wie geht ihr damit um und wie
denkt ihr sollte man sich dagegen wehren
lasst uns darüber ins gespräch kommen
und schreibt es uns in die kommentare
[Musik]